seid ihr bereit für den süßesten Ramadan
Vlog aber mal von Anfang an gestern
Abend nachdem ich da habe ich mir echt
noch ein Cappuccino gegönnt ich habe es
auf jeden Fall nicht bereut am nächsten
Tag habe ich dann die Küchenmaschine
angeschmissen und richtig viel gebacken
also das spätestens jetzt das Plus
verschwinden wenn ihr die Rezepte nicht
verpassen möchtet am Abend habe ich mich
dann fertig gemacht denn wir haben heute
Hochzeitstag und haben sie hatte eine
riesen fette Überraschung für mich habe
wirklich 0,0 mit irgendwas gerechnet es
war einfach ein riesengroßer Strauß
Blumen im Auto als Überraschung wir
haben asiatisch gegessen und hier ist
auch schon die Sonne untergegangen und
wir durften Essen ich werde euch das
Restaurant mal in die Kommentare
verlinken da gibt's nämlich auch
halalgerichte und später gab es noch
einen kleinen Spaziergang